estuve conversando en todos estos días
con ex combatientes muchos sienten que
al menos la parte económica en general
está razonablemente
cubierta hay unas demandas específicas
que tienen que ver con derechos humanos
y judiciales por abusos y torturas que
cometieron los militares que fueron
jefes de los soldados conscriptos
durante la guerra de malvinas en las
islas malvinas cosas muy fuertes como
estaqueamientos que tratar a alguien en
el piso durante más de un día en el frío
con la lluvia de las islas otro tipo de
abusos muy muy fuertes maltratos
generalizados hay una demanda de que eso
termine de de solventarse de resolverse
en la justicia y de que haya un castigo
para los que perpetraron esas torturas
en general como decía esta gente a ese
punto también existe una demanda de
algunos sectores por ejemplo un grupo de
mujeres militares de enfermeras que
estuvieron en el continente no viajaron
a malvinas y quieren ser reconocidas
como ex combatientes algunas lo han
logrado otras están en el proceso pero
en general como decía hubo todo un
proceso de reconocimiento y además de
aceptación de las a muchos de todos
modos viven una vida muy difícil creo
que es muy importante destacar que
aproximadamente 650 soldados murieron en
malvinas argentinos y las asociaciones
de combatientes calculan que pueden ser
más de 300 incluso hasta 500 los que se
quitaron la vida después en el
continente por la carga que significó el
haber estado en esa guerra lo difícil
que fue la vida para muchos al regreso
aquí argentina claro natalio y también
destacar el momento histórico en el que
se dio la guerra de las malvinas no una
época de dictadura en la argentina
y usted qué ha hecho cubrimiento por
ejemplo de la gran movilización de las
madres de la plaza de mayo quisiera
preguntarle por una foto que está
precisamente ahí en el museo de las
malvinas en el que hay un letrero en el
que las madres de la plaza de mayo-
dicen las malvinas son argentinas pero
los desaparecidos también así que hoy es
un día no solamente para la historia de
una guerra sino para la historia de un
país y para la memoria de un país
es súper interesante la pregunta porque
hay como una atención de hecho está
bastante bien representada en este museo
de malvinas donde no hay armas por
ejemplo no hay armas porque no se
celebra la guerra no se celebra el
combate y el enfrentamiento bélico de
hecho una revisión posterior a la guerra
realizada por de los mismos militares en
conocido informe rattenbach ha sido
tremendamente crítico de las decisiones
de la junta militar respecto a ingresar
ofensivamente malvinas y después a cómo
se desarrolló la guerra de malvinas de
parte del ejército de la de las fuerzas
armadas argentinas en general además
siempre recalcan muchos de los ex
combatientes que ellos tuvieron que ir a
malvinas los que fueron conscriptos con
los que habían sido torturadores y
persecutores aquí en argentina en el
contexto de una dictadura entonces es
muy fuerte esta atención en la que el
reclamo por la soberanía sigue presente
no cesa hay permanentes demandas por
parte del estado y la sociedad en
general lo tiene muy presente también el
reclamo de soberanía de malvinas pero a
la vez no hay una celebración de la idea
de haber ido la guerra y sobre todo
deriva de la guerra impulsados por el
gobierno militar hay que recalcar sí que
cuando se lanzó la ofensiva militar hubo
un apoyo muy grande un respaldo muy
grande de la sociedad por ese respaldo y
luego se chocó con la realidad una vez
que fue derrotado derrotada las fuerzas
armadas argentinas se detienen en
malvinas ahí terminó de darse cuenta la
sociedad argentina que no había sido más
que una aventura militar muy
desafortunada pienso muchos indican que
ayudó a terminar de impulsar la llegada
de la democracia de regreso argentina de